[Music]
uh so
this is from a few months ago i'm sure
everyone's talked about it but we
haven't so i don't care um this is old
yeah i know um so apparently we we've
played both of these guys stuff on our
show but
uh apparently the um fresh and fit guys
who you know are the ones that are
always surrounded by prostitutes at all
times basically yeah weird the one that
the one that sort of mayor was on the
hooker show yeah yeah the hooker show
yeah
and flagrant too is that new york
podcast with andrew schultz and the
other guy um
so i
i was only this this the only reason i
pulled this up is because
i i caught a clip of andrew schultz
saying oh yeah you know i wasn't gonna
air the fresh and fit podcast the
podcast that we had fresh and fit on
because it made him look really bad and
they go no air it and i'm wondering like
what could have happened that he thought
that'd make him look really bad so i
have a couple clips here and i want you
to get your opinion
putting that affect on all latin women
which is not necessarily the case but
you want a latin girl who is jewish
right so is it possible to put a
cultural affect on a race maybe when you
guys were speaking about
race you were really speaking about a
cultural thing because if you made a
girl from
lagos nigeria they might act completely
different than a girl that you're
meeting from south florida a girl that
you meet from california a black girl
etc like there's not going to be this
monolith amongst black women right
because they said they don't want to
they black women by the way right
where you're raised will determine how
you act for the most part right so
caribbean girls differ from girls from
the u.s versus like nigeria so
it's called it's culture man honestly
yeah yeah
which are you yeah i mean like i said
her
we're look i'm looking for certain
traits first and then obviously you know
her race is irrelevant if she meets a
certain matches certain traits that i'm
looking for in a woman but what i'm
saying is that most of the women that
i've dealt with just don't tend to be
black and it's not what's something
that's right they go for the black women
tend not to have this is a dangerous
question but i i have to ask so
why can't you just
hear me out here and maybe you correct
me if i'm wrong
why can't you just say something like
yeah i don't want to date black women or
i don't want to date asian women or i
don't want to do hispanic women
you're allowed to say that and it should
be like that should be like oh cool all
right man like yeah you should be
allowed to have a preference i've never
been like
what
how dare you is it because you don't
like black people
i like i will say this i think it's
weird yeah
but
it's not my right to tell you what to do
we'll shame you for it i can i can make
fun of you for it i mean lord knows
people make fun of me and i mean i date
latino women
white women black women jewish women uh
no asians don't like me for some reason
um for some reason they're for some
reason i wonder why but uh
i of course get the rep now of being
just all only likes black [ __ ] mercer
just loves his black [ __ ] so like
but like so like you joke with people
about [ __ ] right like
yeah i just think it's weird when
somebody's like nope absolutely not no
[ __ ] and then there's like one group
and i'm like well that's just kind of
odd because i mean
i don't know but but again i wouldn't be
like why not are you [ __ ] you racist
yes
oh well that you virgin oh i'm sorry
uh i mean
there's obviously we know the
stereotypes which i won't even go into
right now but a lot of the time it
doesn't necessarily matter what i'm
looking for okay so
yeah wait a quick question for y'all in
here
have you ever did a hunt black chick
yeah have you only indian girls have you
that's why again i have so
if you were to prefer a girl would you
date her
question for you i don't look at i'm
like race doesn't come into play like
that's a lie though i'm sorry
i'm so sorry i'm not saying that i'm not
saying why that you wouldn't date a
black chick or whatever but i'm saying
like
everything comes into play like
pretending that
doesn't it right doesn't every every
aspect of it that question wasn't just
race-based though he didn't say yeah a
black chick he said a hood black chick
right there that's a that's a very
specific type of woman very good point
yeah yeah like i'm not [ __ ] with a
hood black [ __ ] like even if she's kind
of cool
it's what's gonna be
around her
like the people that'll come around you
know like and that's just no offense but
if you're a hood person you're gonna be
you're gonna bring hood people around
with you and there's gonna be a lot of
other people that i can't necessarily
trust right
like i just look at the traits like you
guys that's why i don't understand how
you get you don't see an issue with like
here's a great example right
i
don't i'm cuban and i i yes cuban b and
i don't like
dating hispanic women is not something
that i ever wanted to do right like
and and i think he's [ __ ] for that
and hilarious and i like to make fun of
him however i also recognize that that
puts one more latino woman my age on the
market somewhere but you know what i
mean so we're just passing coming in
through the border
if anything you have finally do you
think i'll be able to find a latino
woman to settle down with yeah
current year
go to baldi i'm sure you'll find i know
one specifically that's looking for a
pop
for her kids okay
oh my god yeah
what you said because you both just said
hey i look for traits first like
personality traits and it doesn't matter
her skin tone but then in the clip you
got the same i don't date i'm sorry i'm
looking at the setting look at these
people looks like i'm looking at an
episode of
high degrassi something
like again what is up with these sets
man no not the grassy right if there's a
reboot of degrassi today this would be
talking to grassy talking to grassy yeah
yeah it'd be the show after the show
after degrassi they talk about it it's
andrew schultz
kate black i don't date dark i don't
[ __ ] with shaniqua like you're just
talking about race in that entire clip
he's allowed to
so how do you not see the problem with
the clip when you both just say hey i go
for personalities you said lashonda and
laquisha
and you said you don't
do dark that was a joke bro
i think there's a lot of reading into
this like clip right now
oh he was joking especially shut up i
like it's like that's here's what i
think though
i do why would that dude
worry about
the where another dude puts his dick
that's the thing i don't care enough
like i can't imagine as long as you're
not putting it around any dudes because
then i can't do business with you
but that's the worst thing you could
call it man i want to get monkey pox you
know oh yeah schlonkovic
i want to catch that [ __ ] yeah
believe it's a joke
if your show is educational and i'm
trying to help people and then
when i make when i say something wrong
oh that was a joke no [ __ ] you man you
could be educational and also [ __ ]
joke at the same time i'm sorry to lib
quality i don't know who this guy is but
[ __ ] you bro how about you could do
whatever you want again can anybody tell
me who the black guy who's dressed like
somebody from a different world where
that guy is i i really don't know simba
really just want one of these dudes to
just go why do you care where my dick
goes why does it bother you
i'm always going to be on this side i'm
always going to be on the side
yes that's just who i am i'm a comedian
i support we also can't necessarily ask
him to have the same empathy as us
but the comedian i'm all i've always got
i can understand i'm trying to be funny
and i miss words and [ __ ] but then when
i peel it back and i go to and i dig
into what you're saying it's still just
it's more troubling so say that like say
hey i misspoke i i told you
[ __ ] you bro i'm so sorry look and we've
we've watched fresh and fit and we trust
me we've made fun of them plenty with
the whole 50 hooker set up and all that
[ __ ] who is this insufferable guy i
don't know who this guy is somebody in
the chat will probably know i don't i
don't really watch flagrant we need to
stop the there's too many people like
this in the world and they need to stop
i i just i don't i i hate that mentality
of like you need to no i don't need to
do [ __ ] like even if you think that
[ __ ] fresh and fit is the cringiest
show on the world and they can get
pretty cringy
so what they're successful right people
watch their ship they buy their shirts
and you know whatever [ __ ] crypto
scam they're running this week but like
you know like stop sorry dude
yeah
joke but you guys are doubling down and
saying that you're like there's nothing
wrong with what i said
nope there's nothing wrong
thank you good you know what by the way
everybody in this frame
is a piece of [ __ ] in my opinion i think
you're all just
entertainment garbage people right that
being said fresh and fit guys good on
you for just [ __ ] keeping your
[ __ ] chin up looking them in the eye
and going no
no
and not even turning it into
an opportunity for you to melt down just
going no
i don't see your problems
keep doing this
so far what i've seen andrew schultz was
like oh we weren't even gonna air this
because it made you guys look so bad
i don't think they look bad at all right
now i think your producer looks like
he's spiraling yeah or if that's your
producer i don't know who this guy is
that's what they're saying i mean i
think he is because they're the two guys
doing it look they're
running everything
and then the the show
is
are you sure he's not in jurassic five
well i mean the podcast is what one day
a week yeah bowling yes yo yeah you know
he could be doing i mean yeah he could
be doing both
let's be honest jurassic five is also a
part-time job now that's all the good
points um but yeah i think they're the
producers and then the indian guy and
andrew schultz are the main guys they're
the main guys yes so that's why he's the
producer guy but mm-hmm he's just
he's insufferable
but i don't know but that's [ __ ]
that's cap
hey black women as long as they fit the
things that you want it's not a normal
preference i don't know what no no but
like no like okay okay you're taking
dublin dark as like every blogger was
saying yeah laquisha lashonda i'm not
they didn't know hood black chick bro so
you me he's allowed to
i spoke you made a bad joke
[ __ ] you
i'm sorry but [ __ ] you dude
even it's not matter the joke is good or
bad or anything who made you the [ __ ]
moral arbiter of the situation i should
let you know that andrew schultz
in three months
will be turning 39 years old and he's
still saying things like cap
so he's our age
andrew schultz is our age and we joke
around and say no
joking and [ __ ] around but
he's for real about this stuff
all right man [ __ ] you said it's a joke
thank you very much
i'm saying so you said so you made a bad
joke so you wish you didn't say that no
no good good it's not a good it's not a
bad job why
his whole argument hinges on this
[ __ ] underlying idea that you a joke
has to be
like something true that you believe in
and [ __ ]
it's an example of your actual beliefs
no you [ __ ] idiot but but but i give
you a great example of this can you um
can you imagine patrice o'neil who has
said
the most horrendous thing about black
women and women in general
worse than anything these fresh and fit
guys have ever said you think that
they'd be trying to grill him that same
way like he'd be laughing going like
what what are you weak what are you all
[ __ ] whipped why are you guys [ __ ]
white nighting for some hood hoes who
cares who [ __ ] cares who these guys
want to [ __ ] more hood hoes for you i
guess because honestly and i already
could tell you right now
they put this episode together and they
had this argument with them so they
could all show it to some [ __ ] woke
[ __ ] and get and get laid late it's
just to say then that the whole system
continues
it's but i do not believe that that
producer has ever [ __ ] a woman that
wasn't white
no of course
or like some kind of weird asian with
white
i just don't understand this man i i
really don't this [ __ ] what i do love
about it and you just you just said it
patrice o'neil is dead black dudes like
this didn't exist when patrice o'neill
was alive he wouldn't lit it yeah i like
the fresh and fit guys over because
they're basically doing this move is
every time they're like so uh do you not
uh you said this joke it really offended
a lot of people uh are you not sorry
about the ramifications of your actions
and it's like a [ __ ] senate committee
that he's just like
no
and here's the problem you you guys are
all white knighting these guys are
telling these hoes are stupid and you're
all getting the same amount of [ __ ] so
it's not even like it's affecting the
amount of girls you're [ __ ] because
these guys talk [ __ ] about women and you
know what happens more women want to
[ __ ] them it's what always happens
always
so [ __ ] stop with your ellie comic
white knighting knit cap [ __ ]
stupid ass cornrow [ __ ] but they're
all in on it they're all in on it it's
all work they're two sides of the same
coin they're like the democrats and the
republicans uh you know it's like the
way they [ __ ] us except this is just a
way for two different sides to both [ __ ]
women yeah
good point
you like
but you're being hypocrites
i don't know i i just feel like it's ego
it's like sometimes you get in a
situation where like i've done this i've
said some [ __ ] listen we do this [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] time right you say why
are you talking to him like you're
interrogating him like a cop look we've
all [ __ ] up we've all made mistakes
you just tell me what you did they don't
owe you [ __ ] bro i'm making it about
what you listen i already got you here
all right what i need is your side of
this story i need you to tell me because
otherwise
i already got you dead the rights i
don't even need to be talking to you
right now this is the most replayed
there's no resentment man it's just
awareness and i know it
it might come off that way but it's just
merely just being aware of what's going
on adapting to the situation and making
the best more thing that's going to not
put you in a compromising position
because we've heard so many people oh
yeah yeah
and my fear would be that your audience
of people that really trust you and look
up to you would then
learn you're taking these
guys them
bro you know how pissed i'd be if i went
on a podcast and i was like not only
did you bring me and hit a lecture man
white knighting [ __ ] you brought me
in here
to have your producers lecturing me i
know can you imagine
he's defensive
and then they could potentially finesse
and [ __ ] over other women that were
innocent had nothing to do with it and
then they become the women that you're
talking about why are you defending
these people
it's a show
okay
his whole art like his whole thing he
was just saying there was like you're
weak aren't you afraid that you're
teaching dudes to [ __ ] women over no i
just said i wouldn't [ __ ] hood [ __ ]
[ __ ] weak and i don't know if that's
the case i don't really consume a ton of
content but it might be my fear and i
guess hopefully in the future if that's
the case
that's that's a typical lefty white long
hair dude yeah uh take uh i've never
actually um
you know seen your content or cared
about any of it or anything but like you
know what my fear about it is yeah i've
never consumed any of your content but
what i'm scared of your content
potentially doing
yeah we haven't been hurt it's more like
we understand the dangers of dating
women and we want guys to know look just
look for these things so you don't get
finessed that's the biggest thing
because if you don't know going into it
you can like yeah she loves me for me
uh probably not so it's like okay she
likes me for me
no i understand who you are what you
want why wouldn't she love you for you
you're great bro
andrew hey bro stop the kids
stop the cap i you know what man
i i gotta
stop the cap
i'm probably gonna move no cap i gotta
move somewhere far away siberia no i'm
just yeah i'm starting to get i'm
staying in siberia but like yeah some
kind of [ __ ] eastern bloc some kind
of hungry no i'm not like i'm looking
for real estate on the sun i meant like
in the us but like somewhere montana
yeah in one of those states where you
just get like [ __ ]
90 acres for like a hundred bucks yeah
you know
merch wants to live at the beginning of
shooter yeah yeah i'm like i don't wanna
i just don't want i won't be around
anymore
you're not telling me some [ __ ] none of
us have ever heard we all heard this
from fraternity guys in college i'm
saying there's room in your and i don't
have a problem with a lot of the stuff
you say i just think there is room for
growth and you guys were [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you man you bring another
successful podcast onto your [ __ ]
successful podcast this is weird so this
is i don't what is this i've never seen
this
i i have never
seen
comments
like this ambush dudes and go you're
groomed for growth and that frat boy
[ __ ] so what he's allowed to be a frat
boy [ __ ] in the same way larry the cable
guy is allowed to pretend he's a [ __ ]
hillbilly and in the [ __ ] same way
you're supposed you're you can pretend
to be captain [ __ ] save a hoe if you
want to but [ __ ] you you know telling
other people grow how [ __ ] dare you
that really bugs me man especially when
your show's not even as successful it's
like the balls on you how are you
telling anybody to grow when you're
saying [ __ ] like no cap and busting and
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] 38 yeah refusal to
acknowledge it almost kind of proves it
to me confirms it to me that you guys
are not willing to grow right now in
this fine guy who has lifts on his shoes
because he's worried about how tall he
is like [ __ ] you oh my god you're
wearing this little insecure go to
therapy every wednesday and friday
[ __ ] telling these other two [ __ ]
black dudes [ __ ] made it on the
internet and telling them you gotta
respect women because of frat boy stuff
yeah cause when i look at the fresh and
fit guys i think those are frat bros
shut up dude the fact that you're gonna
talk to a more successful
podcasting duo well flagrant two's
pretty big man they have a hundred but
isn't fresh and fit like they have 817
let me check out fresh and fit oh you
might be right if not they're close to
each other yeah they're pretty close
fresh
and fit podcast
yeah they're more they're they're
equal okay so
so what do you
yeah what are you doing
yeah they're equal they are equal they
they pretty much flagrant has a little
bit more but it's but you neither want
so then but you're still that even if
they're not even if you're not
engagement though they fits probably
fresh and fit has more views and i know
why because i'm looking at their
thumbnails which is all hot chicks yeah
so they they are getting more give and
take have more views yeah yeah so i mean
but what i'm saying is at the end of the
day
even if you're just even
you're still in no position to be this
smug and [ __ ] condescending right
yeah that's the point like equal stats
who are you to tell them what to do
that's some ego [ __ ] we're just saying
there's room for growth a very mature
answer is yeah probably if you say that
to me i'm sure i got room to grow y'all
but why is it important to you
whether he has a personal growth journey
like that's my point why does it matter
to you
what do you care why do you are you
invested are you this man's friend are
you are you married to this guy do you
own land together like why do you care
i'll literally say no we know how it is
we're in miami i bet if you go to idaho
and see only two [ __ ] are getting
flown out of idaho you'd be like oh the
world isn't like this we're just asking
you to look and take an assessment of
what you say and what you spread and be
like okay maybe there's room for growth
and y'all aren't willing to do that for
an
hour and a half why but but again i'm
sorry and schultz thought that they
looked bad in this these guys look way
worse telling other [ __ ] people what
to [ __ ] do on their own [ __ ] show
look that's pretty much it yeah
i'm looking right now
at the uh it's really it's [ __ ]
upsetting me i'm looking right now
at the uh total numbers here
and
fresh and fit
see flagrant
is not growing as fast as fresh and fit
that's i'm just looking at social blade
so they're both kind of close to each
other
but
right now flagrant has a 26. their
social blade rank is 26 819
whereas fresh and fit is
thousand five hundred and seventy three
so they're
they're getting a better they're moving
up faster i guarantee you fresh and fits
probably gonna blast past them but
that's
it's just you know what man what did
what a stupid [ __ ] just i don't know
i was so the whole gayness of the like
dude man it's like maybe there's room
for growth as a person man [ __ ] you how
about that
dude you know what fresh and fit you
guys win you know why because all you
had to do all any of us have to do in
life
you don't have to get violent you don't
have to kick and scream and you know
make a scene
sometimes you just have to politely say
no yeah no
no because i don't have to and i you
don't have to get all screamy and yelly
about it no
being defiant just look them in the eye
and say no
[ __ ] all and all that is all these
women basically in the comments that's
what this was about saying yes called
that earlier yes queen called that
earlier oh you la comics are gross